何か質問等はございますか
先生 今の捨てる捨てるっておっしゃってましたが
ものを捨てる具体的なものも当然なんですが
考え方とかいうそのものも捨ててということですか
うん 全部捨てなくちゃ
はい  何か質問 何か聞きたいことがあるならば聞いてみてください
すいません 今のマーラの話で
委託したお坊さんがどこへ行ったのかということに対する答えは
ゲタにしたというか どこにもいないということなんですが
そうするとそのテーラワーダのサンガというのは
お坊さん 出家者はお布施によって生いっているわけですが
おそらく昔もですね 食料不足とか飢饉とかあって
在家の人が全くそのお坊さんに食べ物をあげられないような事態もあったかもしれないんですが
その時も今のお話ですと
お坊さんは食料を補給してくれる地域から移動しないと
そこからといただく 不旦那話で恐縮ですが
餓死したのではないか
その際に その悟ったお坊さんとか
まだ修行中のお坊さんが
お布施が受けられないことによって餓死する場合
した場合 どこへ行くのか
餓死する瞬間に一切の受け取りをになるから
解脱するっていうか やはり答えもどこにもいない
マーラにも そのそういう質問した場合には
お釈迦様はそういう場合もマーラには一切見えないと
いう答えになるんです
質問がちょっとあんまり聞こえない
遠く遠すぎちゃって 餓死した場合はどうなりますか？ということしか取れなかったんですけど
要するに執着を捨てて生きることに執着しない
そうしますとお布施によってのみ生きる出家者は
そういう飢饉の状態で誰もお布施をしないような状況になった場合に
まあそれはね もし私が言ったように
この この真理的なことだから
真理っての心理学の真理なんですね
だから無執着をちゃんと実践したならば
まあもう悟りに達することはそれほど大変ということでもないんですからね
だから悟りには達することはできるし
はあ お布施 まあもう食べ物はない時期で
時代でしょうしね まあしょうがない
もうということで思っていると
やっぱりそちらへんに執着あるんだからね
だから執着あるならば
もう悟りに達しないんです
食べ物がなくなったら
理性の悪い人だったら食べるものもないし
どうせ死ぬでしょうし
じゃあ全部いいやと 全部執着を捨てますよと
解脱に涅槃に達するんだぞと思って頑張っちゃいますよ
それでまあ そんなに 1日2日ぐらい頑張ればね
悟りに達しますけど 早くこの時代が終わらないのかと思っちゃったら
まあそこで執着でしょうしね
週一回でもなんとかあればいいのにとか思っちゃうと
そこはまあ執着なんですね
だから餓死しても やっぱりその人の心の状況によってどこに生まれるかということになります
悟りに達しない人の場合は
心はどういう変化を起こすかということはちょっとわからないしね
悟りに達した心は全然動揺はしません
一つエピソード これは過去ブッダのエピソードなんですけど
エピソードはありますよ
その問題はどうせ起こるんだからね
今出した質問はね もう一応人間どんな質問出しても
一応仏教はもう随分前もって答え出してますからね
過去のカッサパブッダかコーナグブッダか分かりません
ちょっと今思い出しませんだからね
時代でまあ お釈迦様は涅槃に入られて
そのブッダがね 当時の過去ブッダなんですね
お釈迦様ではないんです
その ブッダは まぁ戒律とかね
もうサンガ 集団とかね
そういう組織は作らない
作らなかったんですね
ただみんなに真理を語って
もう真理を語っていくだけで
それで話を聞いて悟りに達する
大勢人々が悟りに 悟りに達した人々は出家する
悟ったらもう在家生活できないんだから
だからサンガはいるんだけど
みんな悟っている人々だから戒律もないし
もう何て言いますか この規則やらなんもない
いらん それで そのブッダが涅槃に入られると
どうしようかということになるんですね
それから出家する人々はもうまだ悟ってないでしょうに
だからブッダの時代で出家してきた人々が
その阿羅漢たちがいて
阿羅漢たちが一人二人
一人二人涅槃に入って
どんどん逝っちゃうでしょうに
みんな亡くなったら仏教も終わりなんです
では 出家組織を作る 誰が作るんですかね？誰が戒律定めるんですかね
これできなくなって 間もないうちに仏教はなくなるんだと
だから社会的な組織を作ったら
仏教は長持ちはする これディレンマなんですよ
ブッダが真理だけ語っておけば
ほとんどの人々が悟りに達する
真理を語る同時に組織を作っておいちゃうと
仏教は長持ちするんだけど
悟る人々の数が少なくなる
だから我々お釈迦様が組織を作っちゃったんですね
だから二千五百年も経って仏教はあるんです
その代わりにみんな組織を守ることで大変で
もう精いっぱいで悟りに達する余裕がないという事になる
とにかくその過去のブッダの時代で
仏教はもうみるみるうちにみんな忘れてしまう
それで何人かがこれはまずいと
私たち友達のグループなんですけどね
とにかく悟りに達しなくちゃと
でもそれは生半可の努力ではできませんだからということで
まずみんなでご飯食べて
はしごを作って崖に登るんです
すっごいもう梯子でしか登れないところ
上はもうただの石だけ
たった一個の石があって
そちらに登ってからはしごを捨てるんです
もう降りることはできない
降りたければもうサマーディを作って悟りに達し
悟りに達したら まああのサマーディ瞑想もやりますからね
まあするとそのまま自分での神通で降りられます
でなきゃそれでもう自殺するつもりですね
みんな 悟りに達するか死ぬかどちらですよ
そこでまあ一日二日目で一人はもう最終解脱に達する
最終解脱に達したお坊さんが
まあ神通で空を飛んで行って村に行って托鉢したんです
いっぱい いっぱい托鉢して
また空であのお坊さんたち友達が修行するところに行ったんです
行って もう頑張ってくださいと
食べ物持ってきたんだからと
言うと この友達のグループはね
話が違うでしょうと そういう約束ないんだと
先に悟った人がみんなにご飯配るんだと
ご飯運んでいくっていうのはなかったでしょ
我々みんな命かけてやってるんだと
だから断りますと あなたは先に悟る
それは良かったと これから我々の番であると
で 修行するんです それでまあ悟りに達したり
色々不還果に達したり
色々もう達するんですけど
一人だけ残るんですね
なかなか みんな出て行ったんです
一人がそこですーっと瞑想して
まあただ禅定は作りましたけどね
悟りには達してなかったんです
しかし 餓死 餓死で亡くなったんですね
餓死したんです 約束だからね
水をいっぱい持ってきても飲まないんです
そこで梵天に生まれるんです
その人は 悟ってないんだからね
しかし その時でお釈迦様でお釈迦様
お釈迦様の時代になってきたら
また人間に戻って悟るんですが
そのお坊さんですよ 一番短い時間で
二 三秒で悟りに達したというのはバーヒヤってお坊さん
だからお釈迦様の出家組織にも入らなかったんです
その日で亡くなったんですからね
悟ったその日で ですから
そのエピソードでいうのは
悟りに達しない人が餓死したならばね
まあそれでも大丈夫だという話な
心配することはないんだよと
本気で無執着の生き方してみようとしたところで
餓死する羽目になったと
大丈夫だよと 損はしませんと
ありがとうございます
しかし どこに生まれるかということは知らない
先生  はい  執着を離れて涅槃へ至る道を歩いていくということと
それからブッダの教えを世間の人に伝えるという仕事と
その辺のバランスの感覚といいますか
その勘所はどういうところにあるんでしょうか
うん？ 執着を離れ その俗世間に対して執着を離れてですね
その人が涅槃に至る道を歩いていくとしてですね
そうすると在家の人たちを無視するわけじゃないんですけども
あまりそっちの方向を見てないと思うんですね
だけど ブッダの教えをそういう人にも伝えていこうという仕事もお坊さんの仕事じゃないかと思うんですけど
うん その場合でも執着があったらダメです
ですから そのバランスの勘所
バランスはいらん バランスは
無執着でずっと一色で行かなくちゃいけないんです
例えばあの在家の人から求められたら説法するって
そんな感じでしょうかね
うん まあ求められたら説法するし
求めなくても言いたければ言うし
気持ちとして無執着であれば
しかし みんなに説法してあげたいなと思っちゃうと
これがオートになっちゃうんですね
最初はいっぱい仏教を学んで
みんなに 現代はそうなってますけど
結局はブッダをお釈迦様に説かれているこの純粋な精密な出家にはならないんですね
で 同じ仲間からね 出て行って出家して
私はみんなの恩返ししますよ
出家して それから立派なお坊さんになって
村人やら親戚やら自分の国民やら
みんなに一生懸命説法してあげたり
仏道教えてあげたりしてサービスをするという場合はね
それも結局は執着ということになるんです
別にバランスを取る必要はないんです
極限に無執着でいなくてはならないということは
理想というか それがもう何て言いますかね
それがもう本当の基準なんです
ダンマパダに関係ない質問でよろしいですか？十二因縁の中にですね 12
個の項目があるんですけど
4番目にナーマルーパがありまして
業心ですね それから 6番目にパッサ
触といいますか 触がありまして
7番目にヴェーダナ 受があるんですけども
この 4番目のナーマの定義として
お釈迦様は経典の中で受想思触作意作意であるというふうにおっしゃっているんだけども
そこにあの受がですね
2つあって そのナーマの中に受があって
それから 7番目に受があって
ナーマの中にパッサがあって
6番目にもパッサがある
これはどういうふうに理解したらよろしいでしょうか
それは いつもナーマルーパの回転ですからね
だからこの それは説明になっちゃうと難しくなりますけどね
この十二因縁というのはこのシーケンシャルというね
これからこれが これからこれ
これからこれというシーケンスで言ってるだけのことで
因果法則はシーケンスではないんです
シマルテーニアスという同時に起こるんです
だから同時に起きても
また流れの変化もあります
だからこの同時に起こりつつ流れの変化ということですから
これ同時に起こることを置いておいて
流れの変化が分かりやすいんだから
流れの変化を語っているんです
人間にはこのシマルテーニアスということが理解しにくいんです
シーケンシャルは理解しやすいんです
それは物質しか知らないんだから
人間はね だから種があると見える
芽が出ると芽が出たと
大きくなったとか 結構大きくなったとかね
花が咲いたとか 実が乗ったとかね
それシーケンスですね
それは分かりやすいんだから
そのシーケンスにして説明しているんですけども
でもそうじゃないんだよということははっきり因果十二因縁の中でもあるんです
最初は無明って言って始まるでしょうに
心がないと名前がないとどこに無明があるんですかね
そちらも名前がある アウィッチャーパッチャーサンカーラでしょ
行っていうのは心の一部でしょうに
アウィッチャーも心の一部でしょうに
そこで行によって識が生まれるということの場合は
そこでシーケンスなんですね
そこで無明も行もある
心がもう新しい また認識作ったりすると
それで心が生まれると同時に物質も心は作るんだから
で 識が生まれたっていうことは
こちら認識の識が生まれたという瞬間で
物質の識もあるんです
同時なんですけど シーケンスにしてヴィンヤーナパッチャナーマルーパンと
そこでどう理解するかというと
まぁ心に心が生まれると同時に物質も生まれるんだよっていうことになるんです
それで心と物質があると
じわじわと他の部品が現れてくることの説明はしやすくなるんです
心と物質があるところに六処が出てくるんだと
六処があるとまた触れることがあって
またもうって生まれていくんだとという話ですから
パッサがないと色もないんです
一度でもパッサがなくなると色が生まれません
だからアウィッジャーパッチャアウィッジャーというときも
そちらのパッサあるんです
無明があるとき 色が生じる
無明があるときももう受もあります
速もあります 色もあります
これは真鐘で動多心鐘と言ってる考えと近いと思う
それを言っていると考えていいのでしょうか
その同多心鐘の心は常に一緒にセットで入るわけですから
まあそれとは微妙に違いますけどね
あれはまあ分析ですから
因果法則じゃないんですね
それから長部経典のですね
モハーダーナ・スッタという
その五十八節に ヴィパッシー菩薩が思われた受思縁のことが書かれていまして
そこはもう十二因縁とちょっと違う表現になっているんですね
それでヴィンヤーナ 色はナーマルーパ
名色から戻り さらに進むことはないというふうにおっしゃって
これはちょっと省略しますけども
そのあとでヴィンヤーナとナーマルーパはですね
互いに原因であり結果であるということをおっしゃっているんですね
ここでその色は名色から戻り
さらに進むことはないというのは
先ほどのシマンテイニアスという考え方になるんでしょうか
そうそう やっぱりシマンテイニアスということを言いたくて
言いたくて しかし そういうふうに言っちゃうと
またなおさらわからないんだから
一番わかりやすい言い方ですよ
経典にあるのは それに勝る
それよりわかりやすく言うことできないんです
だから私もそのものすごい複雑な因果法則を理解するのは
この経典を通してなんです
だから人間に理解しやすく言うというならば
そこはブッダの言葉で終わり
それ以外因果法則の説明はできないんです
だからその言い方がね
私はすごいよくかっこよく言ってるなと思いますけどね
例えばそこであのあの飛石さんもね
そこをよく発見してますからね
この因果法則の状況はね
あの私は驚きましたね
やっぱり日本で学者で
またその上女性で よくこれが見つけたもんだなと
で 因果法則のシステムをね
で 彼女は哲学者だから
この哲学的に論理的にまあもうこれこそすごいぞというふうに書いてますけどね
だから例えば 色から名色が生まれると
これどうやって証明するのかというと
色がない場合は名色がないでしょうにと
だからそれは明らかに色で名色が生まれるということになるんだよという
だからマハプダラニスッタンタではこの積む論理ずっと持っていくんです
なんで受から もう執着からね
受からなんで執着生まれるのかと
だって受がなかったら執着はないでしょうにと
いわゆる感覚がなかったら執着あるわけないでしょうにと
それで感覚があると執着
だから感覚がある場合は執着が生まれるんだよと
したがってというふうに持っていくんです
だから項目一個だけ切って理解するんです
それで一個一個切って理解してから
これが全部一緒だと後ですごいわかるんです
因果法則を理解する人は項目一個ですよ
取るのは 一個理解するといきなり全部
全部見えてくるんです
そういう風に説かれてます
サーリプッタ尊者はそれをあの
立てかけた足だわという風に
それはナマとルーパの関係を説明するときなんですね
相互依存しているんだと
離れませんと 一つ離れるともう一つ取れる
取れますよと ナマルーパッチャ
ウィンヤーナ ウィンヤーナバッチャ
ナマルーパとそこで持っていくんですね
イークエーションが両方に
ということは ずっとナーマがあるとルーパもある
ルーパがあるとナーマもある
もうどうにもならん それが
もう一つ ちょっと別のことでちょっと質問したいんですが
ヴィパーカという言葉があると思うんですが
日本語ではイジュクと訳したりしてるみたいですけども
このヴィパーカの意味がちょっとどんな感触なのかがよくわからないんですけども
ファラとはやっぱりちょっと違うというふうに考えていいんですか？ 別にいいな
結果ということでしょう
ファラとヴィパーカのイコールと考えていいですか
うん ヴィパーカっていうのは熟するという意味だからね
それはね やっぱりこの瞬間論理じゃなくて
この時間経てて考えるときそうなるんです
これ時間論大変難しいんだからね
時間は成り立たないし
しかし 時間ということは配慮して考えるか
配慮しないで考えるかということがありまして
時間を配慮するとヴィパーカという言葉を使うんですね
熟したんだと 時間を経過したら
本当は原因があったらそちらに結果があるんです
原因効果というような感じで
良いことには良い結果が出てくるという
その場合はやっぱりヴィパーカなんですね
なぜならば 時間の間が考えているんです
例えば私は手を挙げるという原因を作ると
手を上にあるということ
結果でしょうね だから原因と結果というのは離れられる
離れるものかとかね 大きな問題なんですよ
で 爆竹はありますね 爆竹のリード線に火をつけたら爆発はしません
しかし ずっとリード線から火が中に入って
中の火薬に火がついて燃えて
ものすごい圧力が生まれたところでボーンと爆発するんですね
だから時間的にどこを取るのかと
リード線に火がついた原因で爆竹が爆発したというと
ヴィパーカなんです  最終的な結果みたいな
だから時間経過しているんです
時間経過を無視すると
リード線の火がついたらリード線が燃えるだけ
リード線の先っぽ燃えたんだから
次のその場合 パラなんですね
だからそれはもう時間経過考えるか考えないかというね
逆だと思ったんですけど
だからヴィパーカ パーカ
パッチェティというもう熟するということだからね
パラはただの結果かリサーチですね
はい 簡単な質問ないんですか？はい
お釈迦様はさっきの純粋
純粋というか通底ということをおっしゃった時に思ったんですけど
お釈迦様も何か悟りを開きたいから開いたのであって
人々の助けをと思って悟りを開くみたいな
そういうことではなかったっていう
それは私も分かりませんね
だから世に一人しか現れないと
これはすごい珍しい現象ですよ
悟りに達したことは ありえないことですからね
普通心理システム見てみると
それだから過去からね
ずっと修行して修行してね
もうあらゆる方法で心をね
育てて育てて育てて まあ物事の見方ということは一応できてやったんですね
だから あ こうすればいいやということをすぐ発見するんです
みんな救ってやるぞというのは
これはもう後の後の物語でね
もうそうなってくると
なんかちょっと成り立たないということもあります
みんな救ってやろうではないかとかっていうことじゃなかったとは思いますけど
とにかくこれは怪しいな
とにかく真理を発見しなくちゃってことなんです
それで発見したね みんなこの執着を解脱として語っているんだと
みんな解脱解脱というものは
あら これ執着じゃないのかと
一旦執着捨てちゃえばどうでしょうかと
そこをやってみたところ
悟りに達したんですね
それから因果法則などなどは後でね
まあお釈迦さんはわざと考えて
こうこう喋った方がいいんではないかということで語ったんですよ
師匠体にしたこともね
まあ後で では生きるということは何なのか
だから空にしか何もないんだと
なんで空なのにこんなに
やっぱりカツは嫌と いうふうに師匠対を
全て悟り お釈迦様の悟りの智慧から現れるものです
だから言葉で語っても完全であることは完全なんです
因果法則だけは これはわからない
もうちょっと難しいんだよという
これはだけはね 軽く見るなよと
これちょっと難しいということにはしているんです
他はそんなにね まあ理解しようと思えば理解できる
因果法則の難しいところは
この時間の問題ですよ
だから時間 配慮にするかしないかというね
だから時間を 時間の経過を考えても因果法則です
時間は存在さえもしないんだそうと言っても
因果法則です そこは難しいですね
だから なぜならば時間って何でしょうかというと
時間は 時間は存在しないんです
時間というのは無常の話なんです
無常っていうのは変わるっていうことでしょう
変わることを計算するんですよ
機械で それが時間なんです
科学 物理学では時間という現象ははっきりありますけど
それはやっぱりもう変わる時間計算しているだけ
しかし物理学では何か時間っていうのは何かある
あるようですか？どうですかね
知らん 私は 一応Tというものを使ったりはしますね
いろんな式ではね  あるかないかは別として
それを前提として議論を組み立てるとしか自分ではできない
だから距離とかいろいろ考えるんだからね
例えば太陽から光子が出ましたと
それは地球に来るまでどれぐらいというふうに距離で距離を考えたりとかね
しかし物理学ではあんまり無常という概念はない
あまりではなくて 無常という概念ないんだからね
仏教から見れば 時間というのは無常は機械で計算するということなんです
機械があってもなくてもどうでもいいんですけど
一応計算する だから 例えばね
賞味期限がありますね
食べ物には 三日以内で食べてくださいと
そこで何言ってるのか
この変化のことでしょうに
三日経ったらもうダメだよと
だからといって 宇宙の二十四時間とこの品物と何か関係は？全然何の関係もないんです
その品物がすーっと変わっていくんです
自分がずーっと変わっていて
我々に食べられるのはこの変わっている過程で
どこからどこまででしょうかと
そこは計算して三日だよとするんであって
豆腐は二日以内で食べてくださいとあるかもしれません
でもスーパーにある時も豆腐は自分勝手に変化しているし
で 買った買う時も変化しているし
ビニール袋に入れて家に持ってくる時も変化しているし
冷蔵庫に入れてあっても変化しているし
それは止まらないんですよ
それで我々はまあ変化する現象は常に変化する
止まらないという というわけで
現象について語ることは本当はできないのです
何かに過ぎて語るということはありえないのです
それは語るための それ固定していないとダメなんです
だから妄想で固定させるのです
モネのなんだらかんだらという絵は
あれはすごい感動的だなとかね
は言えないんです 本当は
その絵画はすーっと変化しているんですけど
見る自分も変化しているんですけど
絵画に当たる光もずっと変わっていくんで
それ全てまとめて見えたっていうことを読んであって
で また瞬間の出来事で
何も言えないんです それはまあ無常は真剣に見る場合はそういうことになる
それはだからまあ修行するしかないんです
無常は真剣に無常に遭遇するためには
何も成り立たんと何の概念も成り立たんと何の感情も成り立たんと
それでそれは悟りということになる
だから無常を知った人は苦をなくすんだよというのは
おっしゃっているのはそういうわけで
私たちは言っている無常はそういう無常じゃなくて
時間の経過 配慮するんです
人は八十年で死ぬんだから
やっぱり無常だよと それは無常じゃないんだ
八十年経ってから死ぬわけないでしょうに
生まれた瞬間から死んでいくんです
一級的に 何にストップで死んでいくんです
そこで人間の肉体として
我々俗世間で人間だという俗世間の単語は使えなくなったところで死んだと言うんです
だから人が死んだということは
明らかに俗世間の考えであって
真理の考えじゃないんです
例えば豆腐は三日だけ
大豆は一年ももつと 言うでしょうに
本当はスピード同じですけどね
大豆も同じスピードで変化する
豆腐も同じスピードで変化する
しかし 俗世間で見る大豆という現象は
まあ一年でもう大豆でなくなるんだと
という現象論なんですね
だからそちらにいつでも固定概念というものを
固定概念ではなくて 個体としてある
あるということは 頭にどうしても認識のプログラムが入っているんですね
あるということがなければ
もう我々には考えることもできなくなるんです
そういうわけで 悟ってない人はみんな実体論だよということにしているんです
無常が知っている人は実体論は捨てると
そういうところはね まあとにかく因果という場合も同じことで
因果っていうのはまた無常は別な言葉で語っているんです
語らなくてもいいんだけど
まあやっぱり世の中むちゃくちゃ変な考え方ばっかりだから
それを片っ端から壊すために語っているんです
人の考えや哲学 思考 宗教一つももう全部壊すんです
そのために因果法則 因縁だからということで
それでたちまち神が成り立たなくなっちゃうんです
あまりにもおかしい思考でしょうに
そこで頭で概念で取っちゃうと
そこで頭の中で固定するんですね
サンカーラというんですけどね
サンカーラスカンダ 行蘊
行雲ではなくて行蘊ですね
頭で固定するんですけど
行雲もまた変化していくんですね
行もまた変化しているんです
何か見た瞬間で見たということを思っちゃうでしょうに
見たということはそうなんです
そう うん そう それが それがずっとあるという風に
こちらですごい勘違いする
それから それについて語っているのであって
実際 実物について語ってないんです
頭で幻覚について哲学作るんです
それでまあ変化するということで
瞬間たりとも止まることなく物事は変わる
だったら だから短い時間って何なのかと
時間の場合は 時間計算しようとするならば
一番短い時間は何なのかということは出てくるんです
だからそれはまあ本当は成り立ちにくいんですけど
一つの現象が次の現象に変化する時間だからね
どれぐらい短いかはわからない
だから瞬間というふうに言ってるんです
例えば指を鳴らすっていうことは
それも瞬間だというんですけど
むしろはっきりと瞬間じゃないんだよ
無数の多くの瞬間過ぎ去ってますよ
あと指を合わせる 力入れる
離すとか どれ音が現れて音が耳に入る
ものすごい時間経っているんです
そういうことだから もう時間を考える場合は
十二因縁っていう風に順番にしたりする
あるいはお腹の中で最初に命が誕生しても
目も耳も鼻も何もないでしょうと
しかしジワジワと現れるでしょうと
これ時間で考えるんですね
お腹の中で目耳鼻が現れてくると
そこで即が生じるんです
しかし 一個の細胞にも即があるんですけど
だから瞬間でという いわゆる時間の一番短い単位で見ても
因果法則はしっかりあるんです
1年  10年  100年延ばして物事考えても
それまた因果法則はしっかりあるんです
ということ 先生 あの よくその功徳のある行為の例として
あの指をパチッと鳴らす間だけでも
慈しみの念を 慈の慈しみの想ですね
を持つことはすごい素晴らしいことで
それよりもさらに素晴らしいのが
指を鳴らす間だけでも無常想を持つというか
無常想を起こすことであるような
そういうのが増支部経典に出てたというふうに記憶しておるんですが
無常想を起こすっていうのは
慈悲の場合は 例えば生きとし生けるものが幸せでありますようにってことだと思うんですけど
無常想を起こすって やっぱりそれは無常について考えるということでよろしいんですか？ どうでしょうかね
まあそれも瞑想の一つですからね
一切は現象であり 無常であると思うことですね
現代日本語では現象だというふうにね
言えばいいんです それ無常観察ですけど
しかし 私は幻想と現象という言葉と
皆様何を理解するか 私にはまたわかりませんだからね
私にとっては現象ということは
まあ一応外国語で考えてますからね
もうただのフィノーメナンであって
フィノメナであってフィノメノンであって
まあ本物じゃないというね
ということは変わるということで
何事も現象でしょうし
その時だけの話でしょうし
それでまあ一切は無常であると考えることは無常想であるし
現象であると考えたって無常想であるし
まあ何でも変わるんだと止まることはないんだと思うこと
どんな方法で思ったってもいいんです
無常想になるんです 悟りっていうことは無常で悟りっていうことは
やっぱりね 一にも二にもいかなくなっちゃって
何にももう思考も知識も知るも何も成り立たないという
そこで執着も成り立たないなんてということで解脱に達しますけどね
そこはもうもう言葉で講義を聞いて達することは難しいかもしれません
一人一人で考えてみれば
もう成り立たんということ
では まあ終了しましょうか
すいません 先ほどの因果のところで
シーケンスが因果関係とタイムテーブルの因果関係という話がありましたが
その全てはそのタイムテーブル
同時的な因果関係の立ち方に立って見るというか
見た場合 もしお釈迦様が因果関係をタイム的な因果関係の立ち方でご覧になってたとした場合では
昔から昔の今の現象っていうかな
何も起こっていないか
何も起こっていないかということになるんです
例えば何か原因があって結果が生じるように
シーケンシャルな因果論に立つとそう思いますけども
それは日本の因果立ち方から見た場合であって
そのタイムテーブル的な因果論に立てば
実際には昔から今のこのこと何も起きていないと
そういうことになるんです
実際起きてはいるんですよ
人間の目から見れば しかし
お釈迦様の目から見ると何も起きていないということになる
何も起きていないという言葉は言えませんね
それは間違ってるんだよというために因果法則を語っているんです
何も起きてないんじゃなくて
ずっと起きてるんです
現象は 絶えず起きているんです
だからあるということは間違っていると
ないと言ったらこれ間違いだと
ではなくて 因縁によりて現れるということにしなさいと
ということで 何も起きてないということは言えませんよ
これ 人間の主観ではないんですよ
で 客観的な事実ですね
いろいろ因縁によって現象が現れては消える
人間にはこの現れて消える現象は認識できるんですね
まあ微妙に違うのはそれだけのことで
我々認識しようか認識しないでいようが
物事は現れては消える
だからブッダが現れても現れなくても
こんなのは世の中にあるものだと
とにかく何も起きてないっていうことだけは成り立たないんですね
ではなくて 絶えず起きているということなんです
だからどちらに執着するのかと
あなたは 執着が不可能じゃないかと
不可能なのにあなた執着してるのはこれ相当無明であると
私はこの花に執着するんだと言っても
ずっと変化しているんだからね
だから花は見てないんです
花の現象を頭の中で作っちゃったんです
それがあるっていうことになっちゃうんです
それに執着しているんです
頭の中に作った現象もすぐ変わりますよとわかっちゃえば執着がなくなるんです
ということになりますが
難しいんです  すいません
先生 ちょっと一つだけ瞑想の質問なんですけど
普通の時は何か瞑想して寝たら悪い影響を与えるとか
先生の講演聞いてたら言われたので
それはまあ寝ないように努力してできるんですけど
例えば電車の中でですね
瞑想していると 何かどうしても揺れたりするし
そんなに瞑想いう意識もないのに寝てしまうことがあるんですけど
それはやっぱり悪いということでやるんだったら
まあ慈悲の瞑想とかそういうの方がいいんでしょうか
そういう質問  まあね 電車の中とか慈悲の瞑想した方がいいんです
まあその都度その都度やればいいんです
別に  寝てしまうとダメなんですね
ヴィパッサナー瞑想をやるとね
寝る癖がついちゃうとものすごいもう良くないんですね
だから寝るということは妄想しているっていうことなんです
だから妄想を止めるっていうことだから
それを覚えておけば大丈夫だと思います
どのたかって  先生 先ほど出家したらその効果作用にさらされるとおっしゃいましたけども
例えば在家で いながら
そのあまりガツガツした欲を出さないようにというふうに生活をしたら
同じように業の作用がもろに表れてきたりするもんなんでしょうか
現れますけど 負け犬になります
だって みんな一生懸命競争している世界でね
一人がバカみたくなってると負けになるんです
その時は明らかに業現れますよ
最近はそれで生活できるのかっていう
最近はみんな競争しています
だから最近は何もしないで引きこもりとか
結果丸々見えてるでしょ
例えば競争とかっていう形じゃなくて
そのやれることを今やって
結果は後に出てくるのは
そのやったことに従って出てくるんだという感覚でやるという風に思考回路を変えた場合は
それでも同じような感じで業の作用は強く出るのでしょうか
業の作用で出ることは出ますから
ずっと誰に出会ってもね
業を強くと言った方が強く出るから
その作用が弱まるのかと思います
業だと何を考えているんですかね
ある軌道にたどっていくようなことがあると思われるのであれば
その軌道から外れるようにエンジンを吹かさなきゃいかんということでしょう
ということですね ですから
どういうふうに自分の心をコントロールしていくかということを考えるために
その業がどういうふうに働いているんですかねっていうふうに考えながら
それは心綺麗な心でいればいいでしょうに
難しくないでしょう だから
生命たるものは業で生きているんです
業に支配されて 業に管理されて
業に生まれさせてというかね
業が生むんです もう本当は業そのものなんです
最近の場合はやっぱりみんな頑張ってるんだから
お前は頑張って生きてるんだっていうふうに思っているんです
だから 出家であろうが再婚であろうが
もう業のみを相続しているんです
だから自分が業によって生まれて
業を相続して 業に支配されて
業に管理されて もうただ流れているだけであって
全部業の勝手やっていうことが事実です
どんな生命も 出家は長生きするために
生き延びるために 何かわざとやるということはしない
だから業ははっきり見えてくるだけ
それで努力するということも業だからね
だから努力するとそれなりになんとか変わるんですね
それも業なんです 努力しないとそれまた業なんです
それなりに変わるんです
ガスガス何もしないで
まあ放っておいておくぞとなったら
それまた業なんですね
それによって結果が出てくるんです
問題は業以外のことでは何かできるのかと
できるはずもないんです
だから 結局は何やってもそれまた業です
その業によってまた結果が出る
だったらいいことをしましょうということ
そういう単純な結論なんです
不幸になりたくないんだったら
綺麗な心でいなさいよと
失敗したくないと思うならば
それでいいんじゃないんですかねと
それだったら自分のやるべきことをちゃんとやってくださいよと
自分やるべきことをちゃんとやるということは業でしょうし
そうするとちゃんと期待する結果が出る
やるべきことは全部やらないで
一部はここまで私はガスガスとやりたくないんだよと
一部だけやりますと言ったら
一部の結果しか出てこない
要するに簡単です 問題は
普通常識では失敗したくないし
不幸になりたくないし
気持ちよく穏やかで生きていきたいし
それならいつでも気持ちよく穏やかな心で
怠けないで 自分がやるべきことはその都度その都度やってみなさいよということで
まあ流れてしまいます
で 何もしないでいるということをね
極限的に何もしないでいると
最近の人も明らかにそれも業なんです
何もしない人はもうもうとことん不幸になる
なぜ不幸かというと 生命には期待希望があるんです
あまりに無知だから それさえも知らないんです
例えば引きこもりになる人がもうもうそれでいいのかというと
本人に聞いたってもいいわけないんだと言うんでしょうに
それが苦しみなんです
いいわけじゃないかったら
あんたなんで引きこもるんですかね
頑張ってみなさいよと
できないんだと できないんだと言うんだから
できないんで引きこもるんだから
それ行為なんですね それでまた不幸になる
いつでももう何重も重ねて苦しくなるんです
それはとにかく慈しみで
明るい心で 怠けないで
生きてみれば まあスムーズに流れていくんです
自分の業って何なのかということをそんなに理解するのは難しくはないと思いますけどね
もうただ自分のことを見れば自分の人生だからね
あんたの人生は何なのかと自分で聞いてみれば
それがもう業が形成した自分なんです
難しい業っていうのは
そんなに仏教の特色な思考だとかね
とんでもないことを言ってはならんですよ
仏教特色の何だらかんたらじゃなくて
これがまあ真理ですよ
事実です だから 一人一人生命が
人間であろうが他の生命であろうが
一人一人それぞれの生き方があって
で もうどうにもすることなく流れてしまうんですね
[背景の鳥の鳴き声]しかし
すべて無常でしょうし
原因結果であるでしょうし
それでも業というのは固定しているものじゃないんだからね
だからもう変えれば変えれば変えれば変える
また変わって変わって変わっていく
どこまで変わったっても
まあ業 業なんですね 例えば人殺しちゃって地獄に落ちそうな業を作った人でも
それからの行為によって地獄の落ちどころがもうもう解脱してしまうとかってことも
もう全然大丈夫でできます
業は変わりますからね
しかし 人殺した人が瞑想する
一度も悪いことしたことはない人は瞑想すると
それぞれの仕事は違います
業を変えることだから
あんたどんな業を変容してるんです？あんたどんな業を変容しているんですか？ということによって
その努力には差がつくんです
結局努力することも業でしょうし